now normally legible honor on a show
like this we would show a kid of bitched
impossible but you haven't finished the
film yet sorry so we thought we snatch
of one of our own now one of the most
iconic stunts that you do tom is that
running away from something exploding
you're very good at thank you we've got
some stills there's a runaway for van oh
that's in the Channel Tunnel there this
is the exploding fish tank oh yeah I've
just that that's a very good I like
that's down timing is key really
explodes they're real explosions so yes
that one was particularly very crazy was
this the one where no one properly told
you the timing yeah the guy was over
there and he said okay we're gonna go on
three
and he started going three two one I
said whoa whoa stop stop it was stopped
waiting you know we have explosions
gonna go with my head and he said I said
you just said on three he said well I
meant three well what does that mean I
said just everyone's please he was like
2:00 in the morning and are they setting
it up and there's broken there's glass
and just tons of water and he said well
I'm gonna Cretu one and I said denied do
I go then or do I go do I go on one like
when do I go do I go on one are you
gonna push the buttons it can explode on
one it was you know it kind of looked at
me like I don't know
when you hear the explosion just go if I
was you I wouldn't hang around it what
is it what we've done is we've got a
green screen here so we could raise up
the green screen at a great speed some
members of the audience should to do
this but in terms of this Tom so what
we're going to do they're going to start
back there they're gonna run they're
gonna run okay they're gonna run to here
and then that's the table they put and
then they've got what again height and
presumably facial expression so what in
terms of done what's the best way to get
height I think in your land in the mats
yeah that's the idea
first of all watch your ankle on the mat
okay let's get some that's good people
to do this we might people get to you
hang on air whoo now who wants to do it
you want it you want to do it okay you
can come and do it covered do it what's
your name Jamie Jamie lovely okay Jamie
[Music]
come this way come this way up you
should do it
we I'm setting up you go okay so at tom
tips for Jamy before it's so what sort
of a spatial expression should you go
for fish river feels natural just yet
important thing is don't get blown up
put your brave yes you know you've got
no terrified and now you're frightened
but you're still brave yes
frightened brave what's the countdown is
it three two one go
okay so you're going on one on three
okay so it's three
[Applause]
let's see it lets see it here's Jamie
he's running he's running
[Applause]
you would like to do it okay here you go
here you go you're in that dress
okay fine what's your name Mattie
all right ready up here there we go okay
here comes Maddie now so you saw Jamie
you saw Jamie so it's very important to
just piss all over that women just do it
the same right yes we do we do absolute
and things you go think up okay I want
you to think up what you saw in the
playback was it looked like Jamie that
are really big far
okay here goes Maddie here but do it
okay
[Applause]
though they don't they're not mics like
you okay
[Music]
[Applause]
one more let's get someone does it you'd
like to do it oh you'd be so good at it
[Music]
you're okay you're fixed your face okay
you fit right now your fish at the
moment you're okay okay okay you've seen
the others you've seen the others I
think the important thing is
particularly because you look so
beautiful
big face at the end okay so we're
looking for high chair even forward okay
okay yeah you're good okay okay okay
okay
[Applause]
I fear she may not be mission impossible
seven day at the dynamite bang
there
[Music]
you